I get this question all the time Simon I
I buy into all your stuff it's wonderful
thank you very much but I'm not
CEO how do I change the organization
when I'm not in charge where there's
like four levels up above me what am I
supposed to and the answer is of course
you can't change behaviors of somebody
you have no contact with even to
somebody people you do have contact with
no number of anonymously sent books to
senior Executives is going to change the
way they
lead although I encourage you to keep
trying um
uh and the reality is you take
responsibility for the the environment
you can control so if you have influence
over seven
people people to the left people to the
right even the boss above you that's
still a human and even if they're
difficult let's have empathy maybe
they're difficult because we don't
understand the pressure upon them and if
we just work to create this little
pocket of magic what you tend to find is
when you have well-led teams those teams
outperform all the other teams and so
senior leadership either leaves you
alone
or they at least are curious and like
what are you doing or somebody from the
team will eventually get promoted out to
another team and bring all the lessons
that you taught them and Lead that team
the same way and then that you have two
magic uh teams and then somebody there
gets promoted and you have four magic
teams and you have eight magic teams and
then the CEO moves on and is and retires
and before you know it the tail wags the
dog having a top leader who understands
this stuff just means it's more
efficient but it doesn't mean it's the
only way you have we have to remember
power always belongs to the people
that's why dictators fear people and
have fake elections because they want to
give the appearance of popular support
because that's where power is
derived but dictators fear the people
which is why you can't get close to a
dictator's house you have to stay three
miles away and the Army's given orders
for shoot to kill right the people
always have the power always and so what
you do is you create these magical
ripples inside an organization and you
don't even need to convert everybody
it's law of diffusion you only need
about 15 to 18% of the company to fully
embrace the
ideas and that's it tip Tipping Point so
don't worry about the CEO don't worry
about the company just worry about what
you can control